[Music]
meet Amos you can't tell from his smooth
gates and quick reactions but his
robotic brain is rather chaotic a
circuit based on chaos theory is behind
the adaptable behavior of this cockroach
like robot chaotic systems are very
sensitive to small changes which can
quickly become magnified the classic
example is that a butterfly flapping its
wings may ultimately lead to a hurricane
Amos is the brainchild of a team of
scientists based in Germany who use
chaos control to match a robot's action
to its environment their system only has
a few connections but can generate a
wide variety of different movements in
an animal brain say a cockroach sensory
inputs are crunched by one flexible
neural circuit to produce many different
behaviors but scientists trying to copy
these systems have only been able to map
a robot sensors to a specific circuit
that generates one particular behavior
in Amos because chaotic systems can
generate so many different outcomes from
just a few inputs one neural circuit can
generate eleven distinct behaviors the
result published in Nature Physics is a
robot that can respond to its
environment in the same way as a
cockroach it can respond to licensed
sound avoid obstacles thrown in its way
pull its foot out of a hole or stabilize
itself when flipped upside down the next
step is to build robots that can
remember which movements were successful
and Amos could also help us understand
how chaos operates in real biological
systems what it won't do is tell you how
that roach in your kitchen got in the
nature video I'm Carrie Smith
you